that's China have a million to three
million people at concentration camps in
China over there that is not a
conspiracy theory they are detention
facilities in what China calls cynjohn
which is the northwestern part of China
the local inhabitants say it's not China
that it is a separate Republic called
East Turkestan but there are detention
facilities there we don't know the exact
number of people in those facilities but
the lower estimates are 1 million and
the upper estimates are what you
mentioned 3 million and these are they
fit the definition of concentration
camps and we know that this is part of
China's policy to eliminate Weger
culture and eliminate Islam from China
so this is horrific is anybody doing
anything tonight or can they be held
accountable to that to be audited or not
really they can do whatever they're
doing right now
well this is a crime against humanity
this is what as bad as the Third Reich
did before it started the mass
exterminations and what China has done
people we know are dying in those camps
because Beijing has been building
crematorium there's been killing
associated with this it just hasn't been
the March you into a gas chamber type of
killing but it's it's extermination of a
culture slowly and we know that people
are being killed so this this is a crime
against humanity and there's not too
much that the international community
can do is certainly not very much the
international community has done but
Secretary of State Pompeo to his great
credit has talked about this and at some
point you know this is one of those
things where by itself it's not going to
get the international community to move
but when in conjunction with you know
the initiatives against the Tibetans
which are similar you know the attacks
on Christian churches you know all these
things that are occurring together
including releasing this virus on the
world these are the types of things
we've taken in the aggregate are
going to get the international community
to do something to start containing
China to start not enriching it with
trading with the rest of it so I think
that we will gradually I help sooner but
I think that we will gradually see a new
attitude on China which is going to be
we're going to get to the place where we
were with the Soviet Union and it took a
long time
you know George Kennan had to ride his
long telegram of 1946 and his ex article
in 40 in foreign affairs of 1947 took a
little bit of time for the United States
to get to the point where we saw the
Soviet Union as an adversary I think
we're getting there to China about on
China really fast
[Music]